foreign
today we'll make a language translator
application using Python and for amazing
videos like this subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to stay updated
and if you want to learn about more
amazing projects like this trans
language translator then we have a
course curated for the base on these
project to know more about it stay tuned
to the video so this is Jupiter notebook
okay so here first we will rename
language
translator
using python
okay
so let's rename this yeah so first we
will import some major libraries like
Tinker like Google strands
so here I will write from
tinker
import
All Star means all
okay
so Tinker is the standard GUI library
for python graphical user interface so
python when combined with Tinker
provides a fast and easy way to create
GUI applications
so Tinker provides a powerful
object-oriented interface to the TK GUI
toolkit so creating a GUI application
using Tinker is an easy task
okay so the next one is I will write
here from
tinker
import
TDK
so ttk dtk is a module that is used to
style the Tinker widgets just like CSS
is used to style an HTML element we use
tinker
so we use tinker.ttk to style Tinker
widgets okay like box making box okay
coloring background color that
font style
okay the title the size of a particular
you know the frame
okay so like the major difference
between Tinker widget and tinker.ttk is
Tinker widgets are used to add buttons
label text score ball and
moreover however Tinker is used to
style the particular frame
okay and the third one is I will write
here
from
Google
trans
import
translator
comma
languages
okay so what is Google trans
so Google trans is a free and unlimited
python library that implemented Google
translate API this uses the Google
translate Ajax API to make calls to such
methods as detects and Translate
and this translator is used to convert a
particular language to the different
language and the why the language is so
languages is a like many languages
German French Spanish and the languages
we will use to convert okay so this is
the course which I was talking about so
the demand for machine learning and AI
is growing faster than that of the other
profession in fact according to
statistics there will be more than 2.3
million job openings in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by 2023 but you can beat the
curve without professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning
co-sponsored by party University and IBM
this course covers tools and techniques
like numpy pandas Python and sci-fi
along with industry projects like social
media by Twitter delivery service
provider by zomato and transportation
service provided by Uber and many more
Amazing projects choosing this course
can you get hired in renowned companies
like Netflix Amazon Facebook and Adobe
with an average salary high cost 70
percent so what are you waiting for join
the professional certificate program in
Ai and machine learning and Excel your
career into machine learning the link is
in the description box below so okay let
me run it
no spelling mistakes and
so here I will like root
equals to
TK
okay tinker
then I will write here root
dot geometry
one one zero
zero
by
320.
okay
then
I will write here root dot resign
okay resizable
0 comma 0.
then root
Dot
icon
bitmap
then there is one icon you can just
select as per your choice so I will
write here my icon name is logo
simply
dot Ico
okay then root
BG
equals to
I will give the background color sky
blue
okay or I will write down my schedule is
fine I guess we'll change
as per our choice so let me run it
okay
yeah I'll write X
okay first what I will do I will add the
title
here itself so I will add root Dot
language
translator
by
simply learn
okay
then label
root comma
text equals to
language
translator
and I will put font here
as
period
20 volt
okay dot back
let me run it now
Okay so
what I will do
okay
so what I will do I will add a root dot
Main
[Music]
okay and I will okay I have to just
start it from the starting
so now this has come
till here what we will do root dot TK
if we imported Tinker as root dot
geometry 110 by 320 so 1 1 0 is X and
320 is
or height
okay 320 is y and 1 1 0 is X root Dot
resizes
resizable equals to zero zero so what is
this we can't resize this box see there
is no resize we can't resize this box
okay
so root dot icon bitmap logosimply.com
logo simply dot ICU so this is my logo
you can add as spell your choice the
icon okay this is the simply learn icon
so root dot title language translator by
simpler so it is written here language
translator by simpler okay this is the
title and label root root is the main
frame you can say Okay root is the
Mainframe and the BG equals sky blue as
you can see the BG equals to Sky Blue
the root one and the label root text
equals root language translator as you
can see there on the screen language
translator and font is aerial 20 bold as
you can see it's bold okay and Dot pack
so now
what I will do
so let's create one enter text box okay
so for that I will write here
label
root comma text question
enter
text
okay then I will write font equals to
ADL
13.
bold
comma BG question
White
smoke
okay dot place
x equals to
165 comma y equals to
90.
okay
then I will make one input X so first
let me run it so again I have to remove
root main loop from here and I have to
copy paste here
okay then let me run it
okay
so let's cut it
so as you can see the enter text came
okay and attack serial this is the place
where we want to place like x equals to
165 and 90.
okay
so now what we will do
let me close it okay
so here what I will do I will
put one input text what we want to you
know convert into different languages so
I will add here input
tax question
entry
fit equals to
get 60.
okay
then input
input
text
dot please
then x equals to
and
y equals to
130.
okay
and then I will add input
tax dot get
and here I will write root dot main load
okay so let me cut from here
and restart it again
so as you can see the taxes came here I
can write anything okay I can write hi
my name is
Maya
so what I will do I will create one here
box choose language and one here the
output will come here one box here and
the button will hear the translate
button so it will convert in the
you know
what the language we choose okay
so yeah
okay the error will come I guess
so what we will do
we will create the output box so I will
write a label
label root command text equals to
output
okay the font equal to again area 134
and the BG will be same
white smoke
dot place
x equals to
okay 780
and Y equals
90.
okay then output
text
equals to text
root comma font
equals to
Ariel then
and
aerial 10 comma
height
equals to
11 comma wrap
equals to word
comma padding X
equals to 5
and padding
y equals to
five
then width
equals to I will put
okay
then output
dot text Dot place
x equals to
comma y
equals to 100.
okay
so let's run this
root Dot
main Loop
okay let me cut this
okay now let me restart the kernel
the output is not defined
which output
please
okay
okay it's not DOT
output
underscore
underscore text okay
something wrong punch
so as you can see it is overlapping
okay so let me fix this first
okay
so I will write X
100 by 100.
okay so we have to increase the Y
to
180 I guess it will be fine
it's to run it again and again
so why is
very below
Okay so
I will shift it here
okay
so what I will do
I will do y equals to 130 only
and the X would be
okay
now it's quite better
let's
reduce the size of this box
so for that I have to
height is 11 so I have to put the height
5 is fine I guess
okay now let's see how it's looking
yeah so it's looking quite good no it
should be here so output will be at the
middle
okay
so I have to reduce X
chess 600
yeah so now it's looking fine you can
you know place at anywhere as you want
to
so what I will do I will write from here
all also so I will write here language
list
languages
Dot
values
okay
then here I will add destination of
language
question ttk
Dot
combo box
root comma values
equals to language
comma width
which will be 22 okay the width of the
particular combo box
so here I will add destination language
dot place
x equals to
foreign
[Music]
and why
equals to 160
just a random value I'm writing right
now so destination
language
dot set
choose
language
okay I will tell you what is the meaning
of set
so let's run this and see the output
so as you can see here I will enter my
text and here I will choose the language
particularly and you see Africa and
Albanian Arabic there are too many
languages okay Zulu and this Punjabi
Portuguese
and many every language I guess Hindi
you know
I have every language present in Google
Translator
okay so it's
perfect I guess
okay we can increase
so now what I will do I will write a
function
for that DF
Translate
so translator
equals to
translator
translated
equals to trans
translator
Dot
Translate
text
equals to
input
text
dot get
comma to the destination of destination
language
which I have selected
dot get
the function will get the all the you
know the text whatever will input and
the destination language which I will
choose
okay so here I will output
text
dot delete
1.0
and
okay then here output
output
text
dot insert
and
comma translated
Dot
text
okay so here at the output it will
insert the translated text
okay
and then
I will set here the translate button
so trans button equals to button
in the root the Mainframe common text
will be
translate on that
and then font
equals to
aerial
12 volt
okay red y equals to five
and command command
without command it won't work okay
the command would be Translate
why translate as you can see we have
here the function name translate
okay
command equals to translate comma PG
equals to
Orange
okay and then comma
active
background
because so
okay
so here now
I will write trans
okay
I will write here trans
button
dot place
x equals to 445 comma y equals to 180.
so let's run this and see
the error will come or not
okay no error
so here our language translator is
you know set to go
translate okay so let me write here my
name is
mayak
okay and I want to choose language
okay
German and let me Translate
so here you can see my name is printed
so how to confirm this so let me open
let me open here so Google
Translate
okay
so
let's
detect language okay English
here I will write German
if I will write here my name is
mayank
so see the output is same
so the output is same
so language translator is here
as you can see okay let's try the
different language
my name is mayank okay I will write here
how are you
how are you in
okay how are you in Hindi so let's
Translate
see it's written here and now let me
select
here if I will see
I will select Hindi here
okay then
I will write
okay sorry my bad
how are you
you
see the transition is coming right
okay
so let me check one more what is your
name
what is your name and
French
Translate
okay this thing is game
and now I will write here
French selected
and I will do it here what is your
name
so as you can see
the right answer is coming so our Google
Translator
is you know we can say the same similar
to our language translator by simply
learn so like this you can make a good
GUI
of language translator using Python and
you can convert any language to any okay
okay
Serbian
so I hope you like this video If you
enjoyed this video please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and press that
Bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn
till then stay safe and keep learning
and don't forget to check the course
link from the description box below
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here